j'ai reçu un appel d'un ami qui habitent
en cisjordanie
il m'a dit qu'un peintre étranger est
venu à gaza et a fait un dessin et
qu'une fois après l'avoir terminé et
quitter gaza
il voulait des images vidéo de ce dessin
mais quand ils sont venus filmer
ils ont constaté que les enfants avaient
abîmé quelques endroits de ce dessin ils
m'ont demandé de faire quelques
retouches
je n'ai fait de retouches que sur 1% du
dessin ils n'ont pas dit qu'ils avaient
dessiné qui était ce peintre alors ç'a
été une surprise pour moi quand j'ai vu
dans le média qu'on parlait de banksy et
de sa présence à gaza
bien sûr j'ai entendu parler de banque
si avant je sais que c'est un grand
artiste de renommée internationale très
connu pour ses dessins qui causent
toujours la polémique et que posent des
questions qui parle des choses qui se
rapporte à l'humanité je n'exagère pas
en disant que je ne crois toujours pas
que j'ai eu un contact même indirect
avec banksy
c'est un sentiment agréable j'ai senti
quelque chose de très grands parce que
les retouches que j'ai fait sur le
dessin c'est quelque chose de très
modestes c'est juste pour aider en
posant un geste simple même ça ça m'a
marqué profondément le dessin graphique
et y fonder sur la simplicité pour
transmettre l'idée parce que cet art
s'adresse à tout le monde
c'est un art loin des expositions et du
musée qui a besoin d'un décor de la
lumière et surtout qui s'adresse à
l'élite à des gens comme des artistes ou
les chrétiens et ceux qui sans fin
banksy compter les venu à gaza il a fait
une exposition permanente qui s'adresse
à toutes les classes sociales palestine
et c'est ça qui rend son travail unis
hilare du graffiti en général
la spécificité de beauxis et qui parle
de questions délicates et milite en
faveur manuel sein ce qui a laissé des
traces dans la bande de gaza c'est qu'il
est passé dans une période critique
après la guerre est sous blocus il a
laissé des traces profondes et relever
le moral des gens et il a fait apprécier
ce genre de dessin aux gens moi je crois
que c'était un beau geste de la part
d'un artiste de la bombe de bauxite de
passer à gaza
à mon avis il voulait transmettre un
message à travers ce chat pour beth
hanoune en tant que quartier sinistré de
la bande de gaza le chat est en train de
chercher dans les décombres pour trouver
quelque chose pour jouer il cherchait
enfant de la balle de laine ou sont
partis aussi jeune et ceux qui
communiquent ce symbole c'est que de la
ferraille remplace la balle de l'est où
le ballon il ya beaucoup de symboles
dans ses dessins c'est une point de vue
sur son travail chacun le voit sa fin